[Musik]
jeden morgen aufs neue die stadt erwacht
und unzählige menschen sind unterwegs an
ihren arbeitsplatz
während mein mann und ich ausser haus
arbeiten sind lassen wir unsere wohnung
putzen
seit neun jahren
unsere putzfrau heißt betty und kommt
aus brasilien
so dachten wir mindestens gesehen habe
ich sie vielleicht fünfmal in all den
jahren
wir gehörten zur kategorie anonyme
mittelschicht wird von anonymer
unterschicht bedient alles was wir von
ihm wussten war dass sie über
weihnachten jeweils vier wochen fehlte
petit besuchte dann ihre familie in
brasilien dachten wir kommuniziert haben
wir schriftlich mit einem heft
kürzlich stand da möchte euch etwas
wichtiges zu sagen leider ich werde nach
peru für immer zurück gehen
[Musik]
ich muss zugeben ich hatte keine ahnung
wer diese frau ist die uns in den
letzten jahren den dreck weggeputzt hat
darauf angesprochen sagte betty
begleitete mich zu meiner arbeit dann
lernst du mich kennen
bei dieser familie ist sie jeden freitag
vormittag
seit wann bist du jahre paula war noch
im bauch von mama und erst ein jahr alt
und ich jetzt das 13 12 bin ich sicher
dass zwölf jahre hier gearbeitet du hast
du zur familie hier ja das hat die
kinder und ziehen so liebe kinder den
papa sagst du etwas über mit paula du
hast auch die kinder gehütet sind ja ja
ja ich habe das wenn die kleinen bar
über mittelbau die kleinen über den
globus straße geworden karte mittels und
paula max maas geblieben und jetzt sind
groß geworden haben sich nun immer so
steht man ja jetzt was die vorgabe ist
das warum
ich kannte ja schon lacht laut dieser
schritt des alltags sind darüber
besuchen einmal mit der boiler oder viel
anbieten aber die freue mich wenn die
leute von knapp mehr besuchen könnte das
freue mich sehr so kann mich vergessen
[Musik]
das mach ich dir freitag
wenn du du ausgesagt und bastelt mit den
kindern und spielt mit den kindern und
kurs für die kinder ist das für dich ein
bisschen einerseits für deine eigenen
kinder weiter ähnlich habe die kinder
viel gespielt und die ich habe immer
genau dann meine kinder wird mit den
kindern gearbeitet habe das gefühl für
meine kinder so lange gelassen zu haben
und das ist manchmal wenn wenn die leute
über das amerika oder in andere hatte
eine spiegel und die kinder war lassen
ich habe immer gedacht meine kinder
gebäudereinigung für die kinder war ich
nicht aber ich habe geschafft bin ich
hier
drei jungs wahnsinnig jahren gearbeitet
und kann ich auch meine kinder bekommen
haben wir bewusst jetzt und das freue
ich mich sehr denn ich habe viele leute
hier kennen gelernt
gute leute aber schön das war super sich
ja aber du hast deine kinder hat sie
klein waren habe und der schöne sommer
nur in ihrer hand meine tochter war
sechs jahre alt
aber jetzt da die aktien aber damals war
das nicht so einfach wurde es war eine
sehr schwere oder denen das hat meine
kinder gedacht telefonieren jeden fall
schon vorher mit des 20
paraphierung die 23 minuten vorbei
trotzdem haben von hier habe ich meine
kinder sollten das und das machen
das telefon ein bisschen erzogen naja je
mehr das war so
du warst du denn allgemeine kann
das ist doch kein problem dass besteht
man ja auch was hast du gemacht wenn du
haben wer hat das in diesen vier jahren
ja ich war immer zu hause ich habe meine
sachen was ich habe zu hause und kabel
gedacht ist von meiner gehen wird wenn
du siehst wie sie die sachen die kinder
haben hier und deine kinder haben nicht
so viele sachen wie ist das für dich
später aber die kinder sollten das
versteht oder wenn wir uns aber nicht so
viel geld
wir kaufen die lion beiden puppen oder
wirklich so ein automat es gibt es
solche sachen aktion mit einem auge oder
mit
aber wir machen zu hause mit stoff oder
das was die kinder freuen sich
die halb acht bis halb eins und was
bekommt überstunden 32
oslo
[Musik]
wir mussten jetzt kann man nach list es
ist neue 45 minuten und 16 minuten
kommen die nachrichten von apple
[Musik]
dirk ist einer der kompakt
alternative zur bisher ab 130
[Musik]
in der schweiz hat wird die eine
versorgungslücke geschlossen
in ihrem heimatland hat sie eine neue
aufgerissen
[Musik]
ihre kinder wuchsen beim vater bei
tanten und großeltern auf
es war winter als bett in der schweiz
ankam
sie kannte niemanden hier und sie sprach
kein wort deutsch
petit brachte es nicht übers herz sich
zu verabschieden
sie verließ peru während ihre sechs und
neun jahre alten kinder in der schule
waren
der vater sagte ihnen mama kommt in zwei
jahren wieder
sie wird in europa das geld für eure
ausbildung verdienen das war vor 23
jahren gewohnt hat sie in den ersten
wochen in besetzten häusern in zürich am
see hat sie wildfremde leute
angesprochen und nach arbeit gefragt so
viel sie am illegal für leute zu putzen
hat und die andere hatte für uns danke
pro stunde bezahlen
aber in dieser zeit ich habe kein geld
gehabt und dann vor mir war natürlich
eine große hilfe wenn kein geld sucht
habe womit die 5000 franken 14 tagen
drei stunden gearbeitet und habe nicht
jeden tag hat es war nur eine ausnahme
eine gelegenheit in dieser zeitung haben
mir immer die empfehlung kommen dass der
andere leute gesagt ja es ist gut sich
weiter gut
die angst erwischt zu werden war groß
warum lamberti dankbares angebot an bei
einer familie für kost und logis zu
putzen und kinder zu hüten manchmal bis
zu zwölf stunden am tag geld bekamen sie
keines
nach zwei jahren gab es eine unerwartete
wende im leben der damals 37 jährigen
eine ältere nachbarin hatte nämlich
beobachtet wie betty ausgebeutet wurde
und sie manchmal getröstet nach deren
tod fand der sohn einen brief seiner
mutter in welchen sie schrieb er solle
doch beide heiraten und er so ein
menschenwürdiges dasein ermöglichen
die motive brief geschrieben und dann
karte bitte gesagt martin bitte wird
desto mit
sie brauchen hilfe weil ich habe sie
gesehen sie arbeite viel und kanada
street so kam es dass ihr schwuler
nachbar sie heiratete und die beiden
einige jahre zusammenlebte bei dir
später den schweizer pass und gewann
immer mehr kunden mit putzen
[Musik]
das ist da ist sich den ganzen schlüsse
was ich habe und dann kunden genau sind
wir auch da eine von mir auch dass ich
von dir dass sie mit über die leute
vertrauen dir alle du kannst denn alle
diese wohnungen rhein spazieren und ja
ja klar selbstvertrauen weil ich habe
einen vertrag machen aus dem song arbeit
ist und am vergangen und ich glaube die
leute haben wo die vertrauen mich und
ich hab heute und es ist auch wegen dem
fall wollen die leute erzählen sie mir
gut ist okay welches okay bei den
mitarbeiterinnen und anderen glaube ich
eben ist schluss in einen knacks
seit der scheidung vor elf jahren wohnt
sie in diese einzimmerwohnung und
schickt jeden monat 1800 franken an ihre
familien peru sich selbst gönnt sie fast
nichts geht kaum aus und kennt wenig
leute außer ihren kunden nie hätte sie
gedacht dass es 23 jahre dauern würde
bis sie wieder nach hause kann aber
jetzt erst ist ihre mission erfüllt ihre
tochter ist ärztin und der sohn bald
zahn hat und der vater der kinder mit
dem sie nie verheiratet war wartet auf
sie
[Musik]
in der schweiz existieren keine genauen
zahlen über haushalte mit putzfrauen die
mehrheit so vermutet man wird von ihren
arbeitgebern gar nicht angemeldet
meist sind es frauen aus lateinamerika
oder osteuropa die so ihren unterhalt
verdienen
es gibt auch männer die beruflich putzen
diese sind meistens bei putz instituten
angestellt steffen berger ist einer von
ihnen bin ich eigentlich gekommen
da war ich noch kleinkind und mein vater
meine mutter wurden geschieden und mein
vorderrad schwer asthmakranken und da
habe ich die wohnung war eben gereinigt
und hoffentlich ein sehr breit gemacht
und er hat mir dann eigentlich immer
gesorgt was zu machen ist
und da hat sich meine häuslicher seitige
zeit und da hab ich das sehr sehr gut
gemacht und ich denke mir das hat was zu
tun dass ich in der zwanghaften adobe
und dass das eigentlich dazu stimmt dass
putz institut ging konkurs der besitzer
viel unter neuem namen wieder an
aber steffen berger wurde entlassen
darum versuchte er es ein paar monate
lang als selbstständiger putzmann
in der schweiz bin ich gekommen weil ich
ganz einfach mal etwas neues entdecken
wollte auch wegen des geldes weil ich
war dann geschehen aber alleine relativ
wenig löhnen in deutschland gekommen mit
der selbstständigkeit hat es nicht
geklappt er hatte nicht genügend kunden
und auch eine festanstellung hat der 52
jährige nicht mehr gefunden
darum hat sich steffen berger
entschieden bald wieder nach
ostdeutschland zu ziehen
ich war sehr einsam in der schweiz weil
ich hab es ja viele wochen ein die hier
verbracht habe dann immer am wochenende
gemerkt die nachbarn grillen leuten spaß
hatten und so das war für mich ja
niederschmetternd und ja da bin ich dann
weiß dass kleins bett gegangen hat am
montag ein spieler arbeiten gehen ich
hatte eigentlich unser schweiz immer
noch wird abgehärtet und das ist ja dann
auch mit gefallen und dann habe ich mir
auch mal gesagt gehe ich um heil zurück
ich habe in deutschland 100 prozent job
bekommen und von montags bis freitags
arbeiten und keine wochenendarbeit mehr
guten lohn dafür heißt das in guten
lagen
das sind 12 12 euro die stunde für die
opfer und das ist wirklich ein guter
neunter deutschland immer so sechs bis
acht euro
und das musste man ganz schön tricksen
man muss den ganzen monat über die
runden kommen bilder mit 12 eur und
deutsche wieso weiß mit wenig geld
umzugehen dann ist das auch okay noch
hat er ein paar putts aufträge in der
schweiz zu erledigen
ja das ist immer gut wenn sich beim
kunden dass man beim reinkommt gut
schmeckt wenn man ganzen doch schon
unterwegs ist und man hat schon geputzt
heute im sommer ist es dass man dank zur
unangenehmen schmeckt das man dann
frisch ist man hat eine vision für
präzise was die strähne und dann ist das
ok ich muss sagen mit hat eine kundin
bin ich immer sehr sehr gut ist und
sprach die eigene sport zu machen
die wissen noch sehr die arbeit zu
schätzen
anstatt sie ins stocken und da ist jetzt
noch was dabei wo ich nicht weiß was es
ist ja auch das ist damit dort gibt es
noch eine andere düsseldorf ja ja das
gab es so extra dazu ich glaube das
kommt bringt sie aber von heute da geht
es ja wie motten und haben sie schon
gehört hat er sich zur tanzstunde
glauben zu tanzen
meine ex freundin hat mich mal
mitgenommen hat mich gefragt ob ich mit
ganzen und ja da habe ich ganz einfach
mal zugesagt
das wort bild für mich dafür ja aber da
ist eben auch der englische mal so ein
bisschen im walzertakt das entscheiden
und dann nochmal discofox das ist der
große bildschirm locken
ich würde ganz gern mitkommen aber das
geht natürlich nicht
ich kann mich nicht mehr so bewegen
würde ich mich auf jeden fall blamieren
wenn sie mitglieder weiter geht's
ich finde natürlich herr berger ist
meistens alleine schafft und dann ist
doch das gut war mir eine handtasche
also so allerlei sie nicht immer so
einfach
sie kennt sie ja wirklich mit kritik rum
also kritik ist für mich immer schmerzt
brauchen also ich möchte dass dein vater
gemacht habe aber weil ich ja ich bin
sehr ehrgeizig dann selbst manchmal
passt und das selber nicht so gesagt
bist du irgendwo dann zu bequem geworden
oder um hass und das nie gemacht
also das ist für mich zwar notwendig und
richtig aber ich danke mich dann
meistens über mich eine mahlzeit zum
frau hat da hinter dem vorhang hat sind
0 vor staub so geballt staub kann das
dazu verwandt das immer so ist oder dass
bei zu erfolg sein dass wir uns jetzt
aber machen und ich immer putzen quasi
die börse also dass das ich mal ob ich
wirklich bis kräutern und bin dann
verschenken sie
sie hat das gekostet
betty steht jeden morgen um vier uhr auf
nach ein paar rückenübungen und dem
flottmachen ihres eigenen haushaltes ist
sie meistens kurz vor 6 schon unterwegs
zu ihren kundinnen
sie hat in den letzten 20 jahren häufig
sechs tage in der woche gearbeitet auch
sonntags täglich acht bis zu elf stunden
[Musik]
meinl empfehlen noch viel liebe die
liebe von meiner kinder liebe von meiner
familie oder das brauche ich gebe gas da
das feld mich sehr meine kinder schon
ist es her dass weiß ich jetzt in
groß-karben frauen freundinnen aber
trotzdem
es fällt ihm das da
[Musik]
in der schweiz
ich nehme die sagten ja
[Musik]
warum es dann eigentlich nicht ein mann
gekommen
die ist ein bisschen nicht bauen
ich hatte dabei aber ich hatte nicht
viel erfahrung sind boxen beispielen und
machen alles sagen wir ganz langsam
verstehe mich sehr sicher bin ich
hergekommen seien weiter sicher über den
nicht schaffen über diesen absolut weil
der vermieter beginn derweil die seine
menschen so sehr sensibel
dabei nehme vor andere sachen was
zusammen und werden so stark wahr sind
was hast du was du arbeiten
ich habe eine wohnung machen vereinigung
mache ich manchmal kochen mache ich
manchmal die kinder waren schnitten und
das ist in wahrheit war ja mehr die
stollen man die kinder auch nicht habe
gesagt das ist nicht eine schlechte
leitet das wären die leute sagen ging
hier sind oder den us-präsident aber
über die konsole hat oder welche
kriterien so seine mutter habe er nicht
einen guten ruf
ja ja das ist klar das weiß ich dort
mein
darauf hin dass es schrecklich oder wenn
man den brauch hier in der schweiz im
handel
die rolle des buchs sehen und das ist ja
die leute nicht irgend was sie wollen
oder es ist egal auch wenn es zur eiche
mieste genau immer die schlecht ist das
nicht
es ist mir neu es ist reines wunder dass
das macht ist weg die grafisch parat
kreuz strafrecht ja ja eher fraglich ist
das ganze üblich dass ihr kaffee trinkt
mit wird ja wenn derzeit hat mag man
musste pausieren
aber das ist immer schade ich frage was
hast du zeit hast du noch
aber es ist eine gute gute sachen dann
kann man noch etwas reden miteinander
wenn die brauen die wirtin gemeine café
freue mich sehr bei nicht alle leute
machen das oder die leicht max man
arbeite ich alleine mit den kunden aus
und warum waren sie zufrieden mit bette
weil sie erstens ist sich ehrlich das
ist die hauptsache
und zweitens ist sie eine fröhliche
willige person und arbeitet enorm
schnell habe ich immer bewundert und der
trotzdem ist alles gemacht das ist
unglaublich schön und sehr pünktlich
sehr zuverlässig also ich kenne nur gute
eigenschaften nennen die du mir
geschenkt hast kriegst du dann nicht
dass auch von der familie und von seinem
land erteilt ja ich habe vorher gesagt
habe gedacht das habe nicht die diese
arbeit und familie
aber plötzlich habe ich langsam
vertrauen und ich habe gesehen
sie ist wie mein motor ist mein motor
ist das ist was ich möchte und da
manchmal bin ich traurig gewesen sich
hat es gibt auch hallo wie geht es dir
und ich habe so schnell geweint weil ich
habe solche probleme gehabt und ich habe
sie erzählen was in ihrer passiert ist
aber es ist halt alles verstanden hatte
mir eine ahnung gegeben
traurig bist du noch
claudia ist die frau in der putzmann
steffen berger immer noch verliebt ist
die beziehung ging nach zwei jahren
wieder auseinander
für einen tanzkurs sind sie aber noch
genügend befreundet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wo das nicht gerade geräumt haben
was hat er gesagt oder beruf gemacht
erzählt dass er einigungschancen genau
und was haben sie dank was ich da
eigentlich nicht fehlen also ich bin
mega vor dass die gruppe im kopf was sie
tanken aber hat sich die scherben von
analogen wenig selber mal eine gute
durch schaffen und ich weiß was uns lieb
für die unit ausgeht dass eine
gewichtung bessere lohn handarbeit dank
viel geschafft für ihre 20 stunden und
dann der optik der bleiben immer viel
vor ich finde es wird aufgefrischt oder
putzfrau oder klar
ich danke ganz viel augenmaß aber wenn
sie sich zum beispiel lose und ja sie
werden nicht unbedingt einfach
sterbehaus aber ich denke schon dass das
meine mannschaft als putzfrau sind nicht
so intelligent
ja und dann kommt man sonst einfach
klappen zum stand oscar möglichkeit
konnte - billig machen oder eben
sie haben flüchten sie wäre gern mit
ihrem land bleiben
bei putz instituten werden mitarbeitende
oft nur für kleine pensen angestellt
damit die arbeitgeber keine
pensionskassenbeiträge bezahlen müssen
der minimallohn liegt derzeit bei 18
franken 80 pro stunde
petit hatte zeitweise 30 verschiedene
arbeitgeber bei einzelnen war sie nur
zwei stunden alle zwei wochen
beschäftigt der arbeitsweg zwischen den
kunden ist nicht bezahlt manchmal musste
sie quer durch die stadt
[Applaus]
krank war sie in allen ja nie ob wohl
der rücken oft geschmerzt hat sagt sie
bei diesem kunden ist sie jeweils zwei
nachmittage pro woche er ist seit einem
snowboard unfall einseitig gelähmt hier
ist sie mehr als die putzfrau eine
weitere bezugsperson neben den
physiotherapeuten
wir haben die aussicht etwas traurig
warum weil es eine schöne frau wirklich
so positiv aus dem und für mich ist
letzte woche in das geschnittene letzten
wochen einstimmig
sind sie auch zufrieden ist ein bisschen
[Musik]
was macht solche sachen macht das nicht
das macht die belastungen wahr
bei der holding ist einfach warum hast
du nicht gerne weil das benutze viel
zeit das nennst du siehst du in einem
und dankt es ist und den gefälligen muss
wieder machen jetzt haben wir viel viel
geduld hat er darum gehe ich sehr froh
bin sehr froh weil ich habe so viel
gemacht
ich glaube ich wollte das frage ich
glaube dass klasse vor dem nächsten
boxer das letzte mal machen ich habe
schon viel gejubelt
man geht davon aus dass die meisten
putzhilfen in der schweiz ohne vertrag
und abgabe von steuern arbeiten die rund
80.000 sogenannten so papier können gar
nicht anders
die sind illegal in der schweiz meist
aus wirtschaftlicher not die männer
arbeiten oft auf dem bau und die frauen
putzen
schätzungen ergeben dass allein in
zürich jeder siebzehnte haushalt eine
schwarz arbeitende hilfe beschäftigt
maria ist eine von ihnen
sie ist vor über neun jahren als
touristin angereist ich bin seit neun
jahren in der schweiz und habe damals
meine drei kinder im alter von neun und
sieben jahren und sieben monaten zurück
gelassen
ich war seither nie mehr zu hause
ich habe sie seit neun jahren nur über
skype gesehen und sie nie mehr umarmen
können
maria ist 36 jahre alt und stammt aus
guatemala in ihrer heimat hätte sie ihre
familie nicht ernähren können würde sie
erwischt wurde sie vermutlich sofort
ausgeschafft
ich bin ungefähr 80 prozent bei einer
familie fürs putzen und kinder hinten
angestellt und verdiene dafür 1700
franken im monat davon schickt sie
monatlich 300 franken nach hause für
ihre drei kinder
es ist gut eine festanstellung zu haben
so muss ich nicht viele fragen
beantworten für andere die mehrere putz
stellen haben und dem stundenlohn
arbeiten ist es viel schwieriger weil
die gefahr größe ist erwischt zu werden
ich habe nicht viel kontakt zu leuten
wenn man jemanden kennenlernt wollen sie
immer meine geschichte wissen aber die
kann ich ja nicht erzählen möchte ich
aber nicht das ist mir unangenehm ich
wechsle dann jeweils schnell das thema
meine einzige chance wäre es einen
schweizer zu heiraten aber ich möchte
nur aus liebe heiraten und nicht nur für
die papiere
außerdem macht es mich abhängig wenn ich
jemanden nur wegen der
aufenthaltsbewilligung heirate
es ist alles ein bisschen kompliziert
wer in der schweiz so genanntes papier
an stellt macht sich strafbar
dieser mann ist dabei erwischt worden
also ich bin versuche ich sie noch honig
und büro und haben dann per zufall haben
erfasst die frau geklärt oder nebe das
spritzige mir gemacht hat und sie haben
wir dann gebe es seit jahren geldes an
papier und sieht mit putze dieses ihre
unterhalb verdiene ich hätte natürlich -
mach mal so und so und das ist unter den
gegebenen umständen noch die letzte
möglich sie das war nicht gewusst dass
es verboten ist
franz erteilt sie hat mich krank rift
stunden über wut und widerstand durch
das als organist der sohn von der vdi
sterne direct solider pubertät sie vom
kino und die buber taxi und hört wäre
ich mit kollegen hat er ahnen
fußballmarkt schwelle nun ist ein
ko-spiel account hat das überzeitliche
die jungs dann sind sie von der polizei
kontrolliert worden und dann ist das
natürlich alles um folgekosten das
papier kann und dann die installation my
hand sie verhaftet
genau das will und das ist dann sehr
schnell ganges ist meines wissens nach
auch es geschafft sie hat sie verteilt
dass irene nutzen sollten wir ja das hat
sie gezählt sie ferner wurde
sie hat die schließung und die autos
sind einfach müsse sagen wofür sie lebt
und hobby beim bund
soll die geschichte also ich hab usb
stick franken 700 franken schrieb
gebühren und die geldstrafe bedingt auf
zwei jahre von inclusive franken
das heißt für das aber herzlich egal
die linke zieht dann muss ich das nicht
sagen
heute putzt betty zum letzten mal bei
uns bevor sie für immer nach peru zurück
fliegt und ich bin zum ersten mal zu
hause als sie kommt wir lachen noch
einmal darüber dass ich dachte sie sei
aus brasilien und ich sehe wie müde sie
ist und wie froh dass ihre mission hier
in der schweiz bald erfüllt ist
sieben jahre nach biologen bank in wien
zum blaumachen da die erste wochen waren
zwei wochen sehr froh weil viele sachen
wir mal die dritte wochen so schlecht
geworden sagte ich muss so luck nach ich
weiß wie das und die ende ende darf der
letzte da bevor durchkommen ich bin
immer traurig wegen basiert und so
gewann und so viel geweint und meine
tochter hat mir spaß gemacht llambi
musst du nicht weil wir sind sehr
dankbar und so musst du nicht traurig
sein
gehst du so bist du so stark wie sie
genau gespart aber trotzdem sich hatte
auch geweint hatte mir gegeben
sorry aber das ist sie mit sieben ja-
oder ich wollte nicht mehr das haben wir
dringend für meine kinder das ist schwer
geschädigt haben
das ist ja dann werde ich werde das muss
das sagen die mit betreuung für die
kinder das ist selbst hergestellt
[Musik]
steffen berger hat kapituliert
heute fährt er nach sieben jahren
schweiz wieder zurück in seine heimat
nach ostdeutschland
wenn ich arbeite dann hätte ich keinen
gedanken daran verschwendet dass ich auf
keinen fall
wer es nicht auf die idee dass hat sich
stein bloß noch drei vier monaten an
bushs bord dann immer mehr werden weil
hier leerung erwarten kann ich nicht die
schweiz ist ein tolles land und die
rechnung wissen monate bezahlt
irgendwann ist ein dass sport strümpfe
auch mal alles das was
einer seiner brüder holt ihn mit einem
mietauto ab steffen hat sein auto
verkauft es war noch nicht abbezahlt ich
habe jetzt alles verkauft mit naldo und
mit dem ganzen leben
es war jetzt wirklich was man sachen
bringen dass man es mit nimmt oder man
hat so geliebt dass man es mit nimmt man
kann sich jetzt in deutschland neu und
ja das passt dann schweißt uns denke ich
mir und jetzt ist das kompletten schweiz
sozusagen zu enthalten
auch bei die post ihre wohnung zum
allerletzten mal warum ein komisches
gefühl weil es dort in losheim und wo
sind alle sachen sind nach bekommen eine
konnte mir gottes hilfe des neuen
tausend kunden dafür auf hattest du lang
und wie lange hast du's police gehen
vielleicht eine medaille zu sparen ja
aber es geht ich habe das gedacht wenn
meine liebe sagen sie nach hause
ich habe gute sache
[Musik]
das wieder
wo an
[Musik]
betty wird von leslie zum flughafen
gebracht
die beiden haben sich erst vor kurzem
auf der straße kennen gelernt es ist
fast nicht zu glauben
sie stammen aus dem gleichen dorf im
büro des lieber aber seit 15 jahren
nicht mehr in ihre heimat
sie wurde betis erste und einzige
freundin außerhalb ihres kundenkreises
in der schweiz
jetzt müssen sie schon wieder abschied
nehmen
[Musik]
denn
zurich teams bei daily mail
[Musik]
zürich gewann in st
ruf mich an wenn du da bist jetzt
[Musik]
ich werde betty auch vermissen sicher
als putzfrau vor allem aber als mensch
leider habe ich mich erst spät getraut
sie kennenzulernen
[Musik]